ce cas
bon j'ai rencontré un peu rien
ces couches amoureux valence il s'en
fout de moi je pense mais je perds
savais que je devais faire changer
d'avis complètement comme quoi je suis
passé à femme juste du même lot et son
fils je suis la maman de son fils
jacques et très forte pour
compartimentée sa vie pardon je suis
mathieu un ami jack alors tu veux
trouver comment je l'imaginé plus mignon
allez viens je vais à rennes vraiment
breton bizarre je sens le moment je me
les jo tout les gens qui trempent
écoutent leurs coeurs se balance
j'aime les gens j'ai pas encore les
icônes et je peux vous annoncer qu'il va
falloir aux hospitalisés rapidement ce
qu'il a déjà lu un terreau mon nom je
lis pas tellement les vitres auraient pu
attendre très longtemps
bienvenue chez nous je
moi qui trompait rouette tombe mal je
peux pas me permettre une dernière
romance
[Musique]
je pars vue à paris vous allez me
manquer
[Musique]
ce qu'on peut faire des rituels